this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and I
host Startalk welcome back to star talk
radio and it's fighting all these air
molecules like what's up with that we
win astrophysicist people ask if life is
teeming across the galaxy how where are
they
how come they're not just walking into
the front door of the White House we're
visiting us here in New York and Times
Square I have some unorthodox thoughts
on that matter I wonder first maybe they
have visited us in Times Square but no
one noticed because everybody who kind
of hangs out in Times Square is just a
little crazy and then I worried suppose
the aliens visited during comic-con and
they would land at comic-con and
everyone is dressed as aliens nobody
notices
a more serious concern I have is by the
way our hubris forces us to think of
ourselves as intelligent I am smart I am
smart hey damn monkey we have a certain
intelligence gap between us and other
creatures on earth we you don't walk by
the worm on the street and say gee I
wonder what he's thinking I'll somehow
have deepens no you step on the worms
okay this is what we do as humans so I
wonder if in fact we have been observed
by aliens and upon close examination of
human conduct and human behavior they
have concluded that there is no sign of
intelligent life on earth tell you a
couple things
earth nASA says we go into space by
launching into Earth orbit do you know
how high above Earth the Space Station
orbit no you don't know I'll tell you
3/8 of an inch and we tower we tell
ourselves that that space excuse me
that's just driving around the block
right and that dude who jumped out of a
balloon oh the edge of space jump on
this if the earth were this size it'd be
1/16 of an inch above the surface that's
where he jumped right there see that no
you can't see it because it's 1/16 of an
inch so on that scale on this scale
where's the moon is 30 feet away it's
not even it's not in this office just
three offices down on this scale whereas
Mars it's a mile away where where is the
nearest star system forget it
so if an alien traversed that distance
and all we're doing is driving around
the block they're more advanced than we
are
and by the way Hawking is all worried
that aliens might suck our brains out
that concern comes from the fact that
when any of us explored the world with
high-technology ships and and came upon
a civilization less advanced it was bad
for the less advanced civilization they
are they were completely wiped out or
subjugated or enslaved or whatever so I
think his fear about aliens is a
reflection of his actual knowledge about
humans how humans treat each other not
real knowledge about how actual aliens
would treat us so do you have it earth
you